speaking of war
you wrote a book on henry kissinger
it's not a great transition but it made
sense in my head
who was henry kissinger as a man and as
a historical figure
so henry kissinger to me is one of the
most fascinating figures in history
because he comes to the united states as
a german jewish immigrant at age 15
speaking no english and within a few
years
he's a major figure uh influencing u.s
foreign policy at the height of u.s
power but while he's doing that he he's
never elected to office
and he's constantly reviled by people
including people who are anti-semitic
because he's
jewish but at the same time also his
exoticism makes him more attractive to
people
so someone like nelson rockefeller wants
kissinger around he's one of kissinger's
first patrons because he wants a really
smart jew
and kissinger's going to be that smart
jew i called kissinger a policy jew
they were these court jews in the 16th
and 17th and 18th centuries in europe
every
king wanted the jew to manage his
banking and in a sense in the united
states in the
second half of the 20th century many
presidents want a jew to manage their
international affairs
and what does that really mean it's not
just about being jewish it's the
internationalism it's the
cosmopolitanism
uh that's one of the things i was
fascinated with with kissinger someone
like kissinger is unthinkable as a
powerful figure in the united states
30 or 40 years earlier because the
united states is run by wasps it's run
by
white elites who come from a certain
background
kissinger represents a moment when
american society opens up not to
everyone
but opens up to these cosmopolitan
figures who have language skills
historical knowledge networks that can
be used for the us government
when after world war ii we have to
rebuild europe when we have to negotiate
with the soviet union when we need the
kinds of knowledge we didn't have before
and harvard where he gets his education
late he started at city college actually
but harvard where he gets his education
late
is at the center of what's happening at
all these major universities at harvard
and yale at stanford at the university
of texas
everywhere where they're growing in
their international
affairs bringing in the kinds of people
who never would be at the university
before
training them and then enlisting them in
cold war
activities and so kissinger is a
representative
of that phenomenon i became interested
in him because i think he's a bellwether
he shows
how power has changed in the united
states so he
enters this whole world of uh politics
what post-world war ii in the 50s
yes so he he actually in the 40s even
it's an extraordinary story he comes the
united states in 1938
just before kristallnacht his family
leaves they he actually grew up right
outside of nuremberg
they leave uh right before kristallnacht
in in fall of 38. come to come to new
york he originally works in a
brush factory cleaning brushes goes to a
public high school
and in 1942 just after pearl harbor he
joins the military
and he's very quickly in the military
first of all given citizenship which he
didn't have before
uh he sent from the first time outside
of a kosher home he had been in a kosher
home his entire life he sent to
south carolina to eat ham for uncle sam
and then he is and this is extraordinary
at the age of 20
uh barely speaking english uh he is sent
back to germany with the us
army in an elite counterintelligence
role why
because they need german speakers he
came when he was 15 so he actually
understands the society how many people
have that cultural knowledge
and because he's jewish they can trust
that he'll be anti-nazi
and there's a whole group of these
figures he's one of many
and so he's in an elite circle he's
discriminated against in new york
when he goes to harvard after that he
can only live in a jewish-only dorm
but at the same time he's in an elite
policy role in counter-intelligence he
forms a network there
that stays with him the rest of his uh
career uh there's a gentleman named
fritz cramer who becomes a sponsor of
his uh
in the emerging pentagon defense
department world
and as early as the early 1950s he sent
them to korea
to comment on affairs in korea he
becomes both an intellectual recognized
for his connections
but also someone who policy makers want
to talk about his book on nuclear
weapons when it's written
is given to president eisenhower to read
because they say this is someone writing
interesting things you should read
what he says there's a certain aspect to
him that's
kind of like forrest gump he seems to
continuously be the right person at the
right time in the right place
that's right somehow finding him in this
i don't i don't unders you know
you can only get lucky so many times
because he continues to get lucky
in terms of being at the right place in
in history
for many decades until today yeah well
he has a knack for that he i spend a lot
of time
talking with him um and what comes
through very
quickly is that he has an eye for power
uh it's i think unhealthy he's obsessed
with power can you explain
like an observer of power or this or
being uh
does he want power himself yes both of
those things both of them
and i think i explained this in the book
uh he doesn't agree with what i'm going
to say now um but i think i'm right and
i think he's right
it's very hard to analyze yourself right
yeah i think he develops an obsession
with gaining power because he sees what
happens when you have no power
he experiences the trauma his
father is a very respected gymnasium
there in germany
even though he's jewish he's actually
the teacher of german classics
to the german kids this is great and
he's forced to flee and he becomes
nothing his father never really
makes a way for himself in the united
states he becomes a postal delivery
person which is nothing wrong with that
but for someone who's a respected
teacher in germany and game losing there
are like professors there right
to then be in this position his mother
has to open in catering business when
they come to new york
it's a typical immigrant story but he
sees the trauma his grandparents are
killed by the nazis
um so he sees the trauma and he realizes
how
perilous it is to be without power and
you're saying he does not
want to acknowledge the the effect of
that
it's hard it's hard i mean most of us if
we've had drama
it's believable that it's traumatic
because you don't talk about it i have a
friend who interviews uh combat veterans
and he says
as soon as someone freely wants to tell
me about their combat trauma
i suspect that they're not telling me
the truth if it's traumatic it's hard to
talk about
yeah sometimes i wonder how much from my
own life
everything that i've ever done is just
the result of my the complicated
relationship with my father
i i tend to
i had a really difficult time did a
podcast conversation with him
i saw it actually perfect it's great
it was i i would regret it never do that
with my voice
but i i remember as i was doing it and
for months after i regretted doing it
i just kept regretting it and the fact
that i was regretting it spoke to the
to the fact that i'm running away from
some truths
that are back there somewhere and
that's perhaps what kissinger is as well
but is there
i mean he's done he's been a part of so
many interesting
moments of american history of world
history
from the cold war vietnam war until
today
what stands out to you as a particularly
important moment
in his career that that made who he is
well i think uh what made his career in
in many ways
uh was uh his experience in the 1950s
building a network
network of people across the world who
were rising
leaders from unique positions he ran
what he called the international seminar
at harvard which was actually a summer
school class that no one at harvard
cared about
but he invited all of these um
rising intellectuals and thinkers from
around the world
and he built a network there that he
used
forevermore so that's what really i
think boosts him um
the most important moments in terms of
making his reputation making his career
or two sets of
activities one is the opening to china
and his ability to first of all take
control of u.s policy without the
authority to do that and direct u.s
policy and then build a relationship
with mao zedong and joe and lai
that was unthinkable just four or five
years earlier
of course president nixon is a big part
of that as well but kissinger is the
mover and shaker on that and it's a lot
of manipulation but it's also a vision
now this is put in the moment of
american history where there's a very
powerful anti-communism
correct so communism is seen as
much more even though than today as the
enemy correct
and china in particular they were one of
our key enemies in uh
vietnam and in korea american forces
were fighting
chinese forces directly chinese forces
come over the border
thousands of americans die at the hand
of chinese forces right so for the long
time the united states had no
relationship with communist china he
opens that relationship
and at the same time uh he also creates
a whole new dynamic in the middle east
after the 1973 war the so-called yom
kippur war he steps in and becomes the
leading negotiator between the israelis
the egyptians and other major actors in
the region
and it makes the united states the most
powerful actor in the middle east the
soviet union far less powerful
which is great for the united states in
the 70s and 80s it gets us though into
the problems we of course have
thereafter so that that speaks to the
very pragmatic
approach that he's taken um the
realistic approach
versus the idealistic approach uh
the termed real politic what is this
thing
what is what is this approach to world
politics
so realpolitik for kissinger is um
really focusing on the power centers in
the world
and trying as best you can to manipulate
those power centers to serve the
interests of your own country
and so that's why he's a multilateralist
he's not a unilateralist
he believes the united states should put
itself at the center of negotiations
between other powerful countries
but that's also why he pays very little
attention to countries that are less
powerful and this is why he's often
criticized by human rights activists
for him parts of africa and latin
america
which you and i would consider important
places are unimportant
because they don't have power they can't
project their power they don't produce
a lot of economic wealth and so they
matter less real politic
views the world in a hierarchy of power
how does real politic
realize itself in the world what is what
does that
really mean like how do you push forward
the interest of your own country you
said there's power centers
but it uh is a big
bold move to negotiate to work with a
communist nation to it with your enemies
that are powerful how what is the
sort of if you can further elaborate
short philosophy behind it sure so
they're they're two key elements that
then
end up producing all kinds of tactics
but the two strategic elements of
kissinger's way of thinking about real
politics which are classical ways
going back to thucydides and the greeks
are to say first of all
you figure out who your allies are and
you build webs of connection
so that your allies help you to acquire
what you want to acquire
right this is why according to herodotus
the greeks beat the persians the
persians are bigger
but the greeks the spartans the
athenians others are able to work
together and leverage their resources
right
so it's about leveraging your resources
for kissinger this makes western europe
crucially important it makes japan
crucially important
it makes israel and egypt crucially
important right in building these webs
you
build your surrogates you build your
brother states
in other parts of the world you build
tight connections and you work together
to control
the resources that you want the second
element of the strategy
is not to go to war with your adversary
but to do all you can to limit the power
of your adversary
some of that is containment uh
preventing the soviet union from
expanding that was the key element of
american cold war policy but sometimes
it's actually negotiation
um that's what de tant was about for
kissinger he spends a lot of time more
time than any other american foreign
policy maker negotiating with soviet
leaders
as well as chinese leaders what does he
want to do he wants to limit the nuclear
arms race
the united states is ahead we don't want
the soviet union to get ahead of us we
negotiate
um to limit their abilities right we
play to our strengths
so it's a combination of keeping your
adversary down and building tight
webs within that context military force
is used
but you're not using war for the sake of
war you're using warfare
to further your access to the resources
economic political
geographic that you want to build
relationships
and then the second thing to limit the
powers of those you're against
exactly so is there any uh sort of um
insights into how he preferred to build
relationships
are we talking about like again it's the
one-on-one
is it through policy or is it through
like phone conversations
is there any cool kind of insights that
you could speak to yeah kissinger is
the uh ultimate kiss-up
he is uh some used to make fun of him in
fact even uh the film the the the
filmmaker uh from dr strangelove whose
name i'm forgetting uh
stanley kubrick called him kiss up at
that time
he was right um he had a wonderful way
of figuring out what it is you wanted
back to that discussion we had before
and trying to show how he could give you
more of what you wanted as a leader it
was very personalistic
uh very personalistic and he spends a
lot of time for example kissing up to
leonid brezhnev
uh kissing up to mao he tells mao you're
the greatest leader in the history of
the 20th century people will look back
on you as the great leader
some of this sounds like bs but it's
serious right he's feeding the egos of
those around him
second um he is willing to get things
done for you he's
effective you want him around you
because of his efficacy
so richard nixon is always suspicious
that henry kissinger is getting more of
the limelight he hates that kissinger
gets the nobel peace prize and he
doesn't
but he needs him because kissinger is
the guy who gets things done so he
performs
he builds a relationship in almost i say
this in the book in almost a gangster
way he didn't like that he criticized
that part of the book but
again i still think the evidence is
there um
you need something to be done boss i'll
do it
and don't forget that i'm doing this for
you and you get mutual dependency in a
hegelian way right
yeah and and and so he builds this uh
personal dependency through ego and
through performance
and then he's so skillful at
making decisions for people who are more
powerful because he's never elected to
office he always needs powerful people
to
let him do things but he convinces you
it's your decision when it's really his
to read his memos are beautiful he's
actually very skilled at writing things
in a way that
look looks like he's giving you options
as president
but in fact there's only one option
there
is he speaking to the gangster to the
loyalty
is he ever like the sense i got from
nixon
is he would nixon would backstab you if
he needed to
uh one of the things that
i admire about gangsters
is they don't backstab those in the
inner circle like loyalty above it all
else
i mean at least that's uh the sense i've
gotten from
the stories of the past at least is uh
where would you put kissinger on that
is he loyalty above all all else
or is it our human it's like the steve
jobs thing is like
as long as you're useful you're useful
but then once
long the moment you're no longer useful
is
uh when you're knocked off the
chessboard it's the latter with him he
he
he's backstabbing quite a lot and he's
self-serving
um but he also makes himself so useful
that even though nixon knows he's doing
that
nixon still needs him yeah
by the way on that a point so having
spoken with kissinger
what's your relationship like with him
as somebody who was
in an objective way writing
his story it was very difficult because
uh he's very good at manipulating people
and
we had about 12 or 13 interviews usually
informal over lunch um and um
and this was many years ago but this is
probably not more than 10 years ago
um did you find yourself being like
sweet talked
like to where you like go back home
later and look in the mirror it's like
wait what just happened
he can be enormously charming and
enormously obnoxious at the same time so
i would have these very mixed emotions
because he gives no ground he he's
unwilling to
and i think this is a weakness he's
unwilling to
um admit mistake uh
others make mistakes but he doesn't and
he certainly won't take on any of the
big criticisms that are
that are pushed i understand why i mean
when you've worked as hard for what he
has as he has you're defensive about it
but he is very defensive he's very
fragile about he does not like
criticisms at all
he he used to he hasn't done this in a
while but he used to call me up and
yell at me on the phone quite literally
when i would be quoted in the new york
times or somewhere
saying something that sounded critical
of him so for instance there was one
instance a number of years ago where
a reporter came across some documents
where kissinger said negative things
about
jews and russia typical things that a
german jew would say about
east european jews and the new york
times asked me
is this accurate and i said yeah the
documents are accurate i've seen them
they're accurate he was so angry
about that so so there's the fragility
but there's also the enormous charm and
the enormous intelligence
um the real challenge with him though is
he's very good at making his case he'll
convince you
and as a scholar as an observer
you don't want to hear a lawyer's case
you want to actually interrogate the
evidence and get to the truth
and so that was a real challenge with
him so speaking of his
approach of real politic
if we just zoom out and look at human
history human civilization
what do you think works best in uh
in the way we progress forward a
realistic approach
do whatever it takes control the centers
of power
to play a game for the for the greater
interests
of the good guys quote unquote or
lead by a sort of idealism which is um
like truly act in the way
in the best version of the ideas you
represent
as opposed to kind of uh present one
view and then do whatever it takes
behind the scenes obviously you need
some of both but i lean more to the
idealistic side and more so
actually believe it or not the as i get
into my 40s uh
as i do more historical work why do i
say that because i think
and this is one of my criticisms of
kissinger who i also have a lot of
respect for
the realpolitik becomes self-defeating
because you're constantly running to
keep power but you forget why
and you often then use power and i think
kissinger falls into this
in some of his worst moments not all of
his moments where the power is actually
being used to undermine the things you
care about
it's sort of the example of being a
parent and you're doing all these things
to you know take your kid to violin
basketball all these things and you
realize you're actually killing your kid
and making your kid very unhappy
and the whole reason you were doing it
was to improve the person's life yeah
and so you have to remember why it is
what what hans morgan thou calls this is
your purpose your purpose has to drive
you
now your purpose doesn't have to be airy
fairy idealism
so i i believe deeply and democracy
isn't ideal
i don't think it's gonna ever look like
athenian democracy
but that should drive our
but we still have to be realistic and
recognize we're not going to build that
democracy in afghanistan tomorrow
i mean does it ultimately just boil down
again to the corrupting nature of power
that nobody can
hold power for very long before you
start
acting in the in the interest of power
as opposed to in
the interest of your ideals it's
impossible
to be like somebody like kissinger who
is
essentially in power for many many
decades
and and still remember what are the
initial ideals that you strove to um
to achieve yes i think that's
exactly right there's a moment in the
book i quote
about him comes from one of our
interviews i asked him
what were the guiding ideals for your
policies
and he said uh i can't i'm not prepared
to share that
and i don't think it's because he
doesn't know what he thinks he was
trying to do
he realizes his use of power departed
quite a lot
from so he it would sound if he
made them explicit he would sound
hypocritical correct
you